alors là vous faire une interview comme
jean yanne nicole calfan diriez vous
comme jean yanne
il vaut mieux rater sa mort que réussir
sa vie je pense qu'il a eu exactement la
mort qui vous l'aviez toujours je
voudrais mourir pauvre france allant
chez quelqu'un la main sur le bouton de
la manette et mourir oui est ce que vous
diriez comme jean yanne les hommes
naissent libres et égaux en droit mais
après ils se démerdent oui
diriez vous comme jean yanne le plus
beau compliment qu'on puisse faire est
une femme c'est je suis aussi bien avec
toi que si j'étais seul mais elle a dit
je trouve ça très bien avec mon mari jeu
on peut vivre chacun autre côté tout en
étant ensemble c'est une grande qualité
dans un couple tout lui plaît diriez
vous comme jorian le monde est peuplé
d'imbéciles qui se bat contre des
demeurés pour sauver un monde absurde je
dirais pas ça aussi bien que lui et je
le pense
diriez vous comme jorian l'amour c'est
un sport surtout s'il y en a un des deux
qui veut pas qu'est-ce que vous l'église
à ça c'est des propos magnifique c'est
les mots d'auteur mairie il a dit aussi
faut faire des enfants quand on est
vieux comme ça on les emmerde moins
longtemps
vous êtes d'accord is a way donnez
combien vous avec notre ami françois
valéry là elle danse marielle dans un
lent et mon vivant
elle aime quand ça balance on peut ben
oui on peut se demander si c'est pas
mieux de passer ses soirées avec une
poupée gonflable qu'avec une femme
gonflante non ça je trouve pas ça très
très digne de lui j'y suis arrivé